Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
internet un servicio de almacenamiento
en la nube muy pero que muy interesante
quedaos con este nombre internet
arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Asia Pacífico se ha convertido en la
región más importante del mundo y tal y
como ya os hemos contado en la pugna por
el control entre Estados Unidos y sus
aliados y China no solo importa Quién
tiene más o menos bases militares sino
también quién emplea mejor sus armas y
sabes sacar mejor provecho de los nuevos
avances tecnológicos Esta es de hecho
una carrera paralela a la propia
escalada militar que está viviendo la
región Y sí puede que Estados Unidos
siga muy por delante pero amigos los
chinos tienen sus propias cartas
[Música]
históricamente el ejército chino ha
tenido serios problemas para equiparse
con armas avanzadas que he llegado el
caso le permitiera enfrentarse de tú a
tú con enemigos tan fuertes como los
Estados Unidos precisamente por eso para
suplir esa Li la estrategia de China ha
pasado esencialmente por una apuesta por
la cantidad esto es por disponer de un
número muy grande de tropas que le
permitiera proteger sus fronteras actuar
como disociación ante cualquier posible
ataque y operar en un terreno próximo
[Música]
es algo que vimos en cierta forma
durante la guerra de Corea cuando un
enorme ejército formado por unos 800.000
voluntarios chinos fueron a la guerra
para ayudar a las tropas del dictador
norcoreano kimilson Claro que en la
guerra moderna una guerra dominada por
la comunicación los satélites y los
ataques quirúrgicos la cantidad ha ido
perdiendo cada vez más y más relevancia
ojo hablo de la guerra no de la
posguerra eso como se vio en Irak o en
Afganistán es una cuestión muy diferente
El caso es que con rivales
tecnológicamente tan avanzados como
Estados Unidos Corea del Sur Japón o
Australia el ejército chino no le ha
quedado otra que ponerse las pilas el
ejército Popular de liberación Lleva
años inmerso en un proceso de cambio
cuyo objetivo es darle la vuelta de
arriba abajo transitar desde la idea del
Soldado como corazón del ejército a la
tecnología como núcleo esencial de las
fuerzas armadas la fecha para lograrlo
también está fijada el año 2049 pero
evidentemente no hay recursos para todo
De hecho ya os contamos en un pasado
vídeo que la diferencia de presupuesto
militar entre los Estados Unidos y China
puede ser mucho más grande de lo que
pensamos a primera vista Así que en
otras palabras los líderes chinos han
tenido que escoger En qué tipo de guerra
quieren destacar Así que la pregunta que
casi todos seguro seguros estáis
haciendo Es por donde van los tiros
Cuáles son exactamente los tipos de
armas con las que los líderes chinos
aspiran a tener la hegemonía de Asia
Pacífico qué demonios tienen en mente
básicamente el régimen chino está
apostando por la superioridad aérea
convencional mediante las tecnologías de
sigilo así como por las conocidas como
armas de nuevo concepto las armas de
nuevo concepto es una tipología de
armamento que a su vez se divide en tres
grandes subgrupos primero las armas de
energía dirigida como las tecnologías de
pulso electromagnético o las armas láser
segundo las armas de información como
son los vídeos informáticos y los
sistemas de hackeo y tercero las armas
biológicas o químicas como es el caso
por ejemplo de las desarrolladas con
virus irritados genéticamente
stop que ya sé lo que estáis pensando no
esto último no es en absoluto ninguna
referencia al sars coronavirus 2 que nos
conocemos
Pues bien El caso es que los científicos
militares chinos llevan años trabajando
en todos y cada uno de estos tres Campos
con una idea crear un novedoso sistema
militar que sea capaz de atacar de la
forma más eficiente multiplicar los
daños e incluso ser invisible muchos de
vosotros quizás nunca hayáis oído hablar
de algunas de las armas que os vamos a
mostrar porque no este vídeo no va de ni
portaaviones ni fragatas tanques ni de
ninguna otra cosa que recuerde
esencialmente al siglo 20 atentos
pero un momento antes de continuar con
el vídeo me gustaría hablaros de
internet
[Música]
como sabéis en visualpolitik trabajamos
con mucha muchísima documentación nos
preocupa mucho la seguridad y la
privacidad por eso esta empresa nos ha
llamado muchísimo la atención internet
es un servicio de almacenamiento en la
nube que no solo te permite organizar
mejor tus documentos sino que además es
mucho más seguro que los servicios en la
nube de las bictech Pero cuál es la
diferencia pues veréis internet encripta
todos tus datos y no Guarda tu clave de
encriptación para que nos entendamos
esto significa que solo tú tienes acceso
a tus datos nadie más interesante nos
parece internet Quiere convertirse en
una alternativa para almacenar datos en
la nube centrada sobre todo en la
seguridad y la confidencialidad de toda
tu información y además tienen varios
planes de suscripción que se adaptan a
las necesidades de cada usuario pero
sabéis que es lo mejor que solo por
haber visto Este vídeo Sí este vídeo
tendrás un mes gratis al suscribirte a
su plan de 2 tera Así que no pierdas la
oportunidad de probar internet con esta
oferta exclusiva introduciendo el cupón
visualpolitik cuando elijas tu plan os
dejamos el enlace a su web abajo en la
descripción dicho esto continuemos
las armas de energía dirigida
Seguro seguro que todos habéis oído
hablar de las armas láser me juego un
brazo a que sí es una idea que puede
parecer sacada de Star Wars pero que ya
existe en el mundo militar Y que en
diferentes fases experimentales está ya
siendo probada por ejércitos como los de
Estados Unidos Rusia y sí también china
sin embargo las armas láser son tan solo
uno de los tipos de armas que podemos
encontrar dentro de una categoría más
amplia la de las armas de energía
dirigida
las armas de energía dirigida son un
tipo de armas de Última Generación que
utilizan proyectiles que no son sólidos
Como por ejemplo láser o plasma o dicho
de otra forma No disparan proyectiles
tal y como los conocemos normalmente lo
que tiene importantes ventajas por un
lado potencialmente pueden ser mucho más
baratas una vez son producidas porque no
necesitan munición y por otro lado hoy
por hoy el ataque no puede ser detenido
por ningún tipo de escudo o de sistema
además son armas muy precisas que
generan menos deflagraciones y daños
colaterales el problema que debido
precisamente a Estos factores bajo coste
y alta dificultad para evitar el ataque
son también armas más peligrosas que las
convencionales especialmente sin el
futuro consiguen dar el Salto evolutivo
que los ejércitos de las grandes
potencias están buscando
[Música]
en el caso de china en 2017 el país dio
a conocer un sistema de armas láser
llamado Silent Hunter que traducido al
español significa cazador silencioso
este sistema ha sido desarrollado por la
empresa polit technologies perteneciente
al grupo empresarial público china Polly
Group Corporation el artefacto consta de
un cañón láser montado sobre un camión y
alimentado por electricidad utilizando
la máxima potencia el láser llega a
tener un alcance de 4 km sin apenas
perder efectividad destructiva para que
os hagáis una idea de su potencia es
capaz de penetrar cinco placas de acero
de 2 milímetros de grosor cada una a 800
metros de distancia o una sola placa de
5 milímetros si hablamos de un kilómetro
esto traducido a la vida real implicaría
que en distancias cortas el Silent
Hunter sería capaz de comprometer
incluso a vehículos blindados ligeros en
hipotético a la vez que improbable
combate terrestre
ahora bien la pregunta clave para que
demonios quiere china este sistema Pues
en principio no parece que la idea sea
ofensiva sino más bien todo lo contrario
aunque con matices porque bueno la
enemistad entre India y China podría
terminar haciendo la protagonista pero
no nos desviemos por un lado este láser
podría ser enormemente útil como defensa
antidrones de baja altura siempre y
cuando no olvidemos que con un alcance
de un kilómetro la máxima potencia y que
los drones militares más avanzados
pueden volar a unos 15.000 metros de
altura este láser tiene hoy por hoy una
aplicación muy limitada en materia
defensiva
[Música]
según Pekín por ahora su utilidad pasa
por proteger instalaciones sensibles o
incluso eventos multitudinarios del
vuelo de drones motorizados drones que
por ejemplo pudieran suponer una amenaza
terrorista Aunque lo cierto Es que en
alguna ocasión Los Estados Unidos ya se
han quejado de que china ha utilizado
este u otro sistema similar para apuntar
a los pilotos estadounidenses de aviones
c-130 Hércules mientras volaban en
yibuti donde China tiene su única base
militar en el extranjero causando con
ello heridas Menores en los ojos de
algunos de estos pilotos
ensayos sea como sea y tenga el futuro
que tenga este arma láser no es la única
arma de energía dirigida que china está
desarrollando fijaos china podría haber
probado una nueva arma electromagnética
Pero qué día antes es esto de un
artefacto electromagnético exactamente
Pues bien hay dos formas principales de
usar la fuerza electromagnética en la
guerra una más espectacular que otra y
en ambos tipos china Ha logrado ya
importantes avances
por un lado están los ataques de pulso
electromagnético que mediante el envío
de un pulso similar a cuando se produce
una fuerte llamarada solar son capaces
de poner en jaque todo el sistema
eléctrico de un país así como todo
aquello que utilice electricidad o
geoposicionamiento no Esto no es ninguna
teoría conspiranoica ni ninguna idea
alocada es la realidad Pero cómo creéis
que se podría conseguir de forma
artificial energía electromagnética tan
descomunal alguna idea
pues por ejemplo mediante armas
nucleares concretamente a través de una
tecnología particular de misiles y la
tecnología de la bomba de hidrógeno o
termonuclear se puede conseguir provocar
un enorme pulso electromagnético si se
detona a gran altitud sobre el lugar del
ataque
en teoría este tipo de ataques no tienen
los efectos negativos y destructivos de
un ataque nuclear convencional pero el
caos que pueden llegar a provocar es
inmenso China tiene la capacidad de un
primer golpe que funda la red eléctrica
de Estados Unidos con un arma de pulso
electromagnético impresionados Pues es
verdad ver lo que es capaz de hacer
China desde un simple barco los
protagonistas Los cañones de riel
electromagnéticos
[Música]
y los que más sabéis de esto diréis pero
Alberto si esto no es nada nuevo y es
verdad el aire conceptual es bastante
antigua Data de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial de hecho tenemos un vídeo
dedicado al tema en nuestro canal de
Mega projects echándole un ojo la
diferencia entre los de esa época y los
actuales su aplicación y obviamente sus
mejoras en fuerza y precisión en el caso
de china en 2018 apareció en Luján un
enorme cañón de riel electromagnético
montado en la proa del buque High and
shang
este tipo de arma no es exactamente un
arma de energía dirigida ya que dispara
un proyectil pero lo hace montandolo en
dos rieles conductores paralelos
cargados con una cantidad enorme de
Electricidad lo que crea un campo
magnético esto permite que el proyectil
salga del cañón a velocidades
supersónicas gracias a la fuerza de
Lawrence de esta forma multiplica la
destrucción en blancos con cinturones
acorazados Como por ejemplo son Los
buques de guerra
precisamente por esto china lo ha
probado a bordo de un barco Pekín cree
que este arma le puede dar superioridad
naval a su Marina y claro evidentemente
una superioridad numérica y también
tecnológica es clave para que china
pueda cumplir su sueño de controlar los
mares de la región hacia Pacífico sobre
todo el de la china meridional ahora
bien llegados a este punto seguro que os
estáis preguntando por el resto de armas
de las que o si vamos a hablar en este
vídeo Pues bien Vamos allá
la guerra del futuro está en el aire
os acordáis del mítico Bombardero
estadounidense f-17 nighthawk este avión
tan extraño que cautivó a Los amantes de
la Aviación militar y cuya principal
característica era ser el primer
Bombardero invisible del mundo apuesto a
que sí pues bien la tecnología del
sigilo ya no es algo tan exclusivo de
hecho muchos países con programas más o
menos potentes de desarrollo de aviones
militares ya han adoptado esta
tecnología total o parcialmente Y sí
china también es uno de ellos
[Música]
Este es el caso del kazache indujota 20
que si la sinuosas formas geométricas
del f-17 es también un avión invisible o
furtivo de quinta generación O al menos
eso es lo que decía Pekín hasta hace
poco la cuestión es que este es el
primer caza con tecnología de sigilo
desarrollado íntegramente en el gigante
asiático un caza ha diseñado
supuestamente para competir con otros
tres cazas furtivos avanzados que están
actualmente en servicio los f-22 y F
estadounidenses y el sukoi sub-57 ruso
hoy por hoy sin embargo son muchos
expertos en la materia los que coinciden
en que el j20 no reúne los requisitos
necesarios como para ser considerado un
caza de quinta generación sino que se
situaría en algún punto entre la cuarta
generación y la 4.5 en cualquier caso lo
que más se discute sobre este aparato lo
es eso sino cómo se desarrolló
concretamente existen muchas sospechas
de que tiene detrás toda una historia de
espionaje militar a los programas
estadounidenses de los cazas f-35 Y f22
sí tal cual como lo hizo
[Música]
los hit Martin la compañía
desarrolladora de estos dos modelos está
convencida de que hacker chinos robaran
documentos técnicos del f-35 en 2007 y
también penetraron en la red de un
subcontratista australiano del programa
también están seguros de que el modelo
chino incluye tecnología robada del
programa f22 ahora bien En qué se basan
Pues bien según Fuentes estadounidenses
el sistema de sensores del j20 es casi
clavado al del f-22 y no solo eso parece
copiar al f-35 en cosas tan importantes
como el radar o las calibraciones del
motor el robo de tecnología militar
occidental por parte de China ha sido
durante mucho tiempo más que una
sospecha prácticamente un Secreto a
voces en este caso incluso Edward
snowden que no está precisamente bien
visto por el gobierno de los Estados
Unidos confirma que efectivamente china
robó muchos terabytes de datos de
información clasificada sobre el f-35
nuevos documentos de snowden revelan que
los chinos están detrás del hackeo al
f-35 amigos uno de los sueños militares
que Pekín siempre ha tenido es romper la
brecha aérea con Estados Unidos
hoy por hoy los expertos consideran que
las características de este avión son
muy inferiores a las de sus competidores
norteamericanos y que no tiene la
capacidad de ganar en un enfrentamiento
abierto Eso sí su propia evolución
supone Un paso adelante decisivo para la
industria militar china es Por así
decirlo su primera gran incursión en el
campo de los gigantes del aire
una incursión con una importante ventaja
sin el f-35 para Taiwán podría resultar
muy complicado contener un ataque masivo
con este avión precisamente por eso las
autoridades taiwanesas llevan años
pidiendo a Estados Unidos que les
permitan comprar el f-35 pero la
respuesta de Los Americanos ha sido
bueno dar largas o hablar de un leasing
que bueno pues de momento no llega
las ventas de aviones de combate Taiwán
y el complejo equilibrio de poder entre
Estados Unidos y China Taiwán quería
casas f-35b con capacidad de aterrizaje
y despegue vertical corto para preservar
su capacidad aérea en caso de sufrir
ataques Sorpresas del ejército Popular
de liberación sobre aeródromos
taiwaneses que inhabilitarán las pistas
estos intentos por negociar la venta sin
embargo se vieron obstaculizados por la
administración de Obama y en su lugar
ofreció el paquete de actualización del
f-16 a Taiwán No hay forma parece que
Washington no quiere abrir el melón
político que se opondría que taipei
tuviera sus propios cazas f-35 de
momento
americana ha sido mover de vez en cuando
portaaviones a la zona cargados con
estos aviones pero los taiwaneses no
tienen la seguridad de que ante un
ataque real chino Estados Unidos llegara
a entrar en combate y Por ese motivo
lógicamente quieren tener sus propios
f-35 pero ojo porque el caza chendu j-20
no es la única amenaza sigilosa China
china también está trabajando en el
desarrollo de un avanzado modelo de dron
El vwj700 junto con el drone invisible
skyhow china podría realizar
reconocimientos en entornos hostiles y
luego atacar desde gran altitud el wj700
es un salto cualitativo brutal en el
programa de drones chinos ya que es el
único dron de Gran altitud alta
velocidad y largo Rango capaz de
ejecutar misiones de ataque en concreto
puede realizar ataques de precisión aire
superficie en múltiples situaciones algo
que lo pone casi a la altura de los
drones estadounidenses más modernos
la ventaja que le daría este tipo de
armas a piquín para operar en el
extranjero podría cambiar en el futuro
la estrategia militar y diplomática de
Pekín en fin solo el tiempo dirá Amigas
y amigos de visualpolitik estas son solo
unas pocas de las muchas nuevas armas
con las que china quiere dar el golpe en
la mesa en el futuro Hay muchísimas más
de todas las formas y colores incluido
un sistema de guerra espacial
Sí sí lo habéis escuchado bien china
está desarrollando un sistema asad de
destrucción de satélites mediante
cohetes espaciales una capacidad que ya
tenía la unión soviética durante la
Guerra Fría y luego están los temas de
los virus modificados genéticamente o
las ciberguerras ámbitos de los que
seguro hablaremos más adelante
china sigue muy lejos de Estados Unidos
y evidentemente los norteamericanos
tienen sus propios programas de armas
tecnológicamente avanzadas pero la
puerta china está sobre la mesa y en
ella las armas de energía dirigida los
cazas de quinta y los drones avanzados
juegan un papel clave también los
misiles Supersónicos con los que las
fuerzas armadas chinas esperan dejar
fuera de combate por obsoleta a la
mismísima marina norteamericana
china prueba nueva nueva capacidad
espacial con misiles hipersónicos el
lanzamiento en agosto de cohetes con
capacidad nuclear dio la vuelta al mundo
y tomó por sorpresa la inteligencia
estadounidense pero dicho esto turno
para ti crees que china logrará
equipararse a la fuerza de Estados
Unidos en Asia Pacífico déjanos tu
comentario por aquí abajo y si te ha
gustado este vídeo No olvides darle a
like y suscribirte aviso al politik si
aún no lo has hecho una vez más gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]